doucement en fait qu'un mais
doucement là ça va c'est
bon joli ça les chameau devant
lesol
de
bonjour voilà voilà regarde regarde
comme c'est
beau couleur magnifique
regarde tout large
là
presque blanc beau ce blanc de voà voà
pas les tombes avant de
monter
as tout raconter là tu
vois on un petit peu de jus pour
faire pour
faireignonsite l'ombre ça va
pas est assez loin de l'ombre tu peux
c'est pe très loin de l'ombre tu peux tu
peux piquer un tout tu peux plus
d'acord tu veux contourner autour non
non tu vas voir attends
attends on finit avec ouou toute
l'emphilade fix
verticale mais pas longbre
non leage commence à devenir beau le
village commence à devenir beau voilà tu
as tout le rocher c'est magnifique c'est
bravo les enfants bravo ça c'est une
bonne
idée oh la vache c'est super avec tous
les truc je m'arrête quand on voit la
pointe d'accord ça pas
ok super beau ce village
là
contrejour
oh là là regarde le village là come il
est
beau
voilà vend le bien large he c'est super
beau ça de voir la pointe c'est
beauon
voilà
c'est derrière exactement compris je
descend un tout petit peu tu
vois continuer comme
çaon
ok tu faire avec
OK dedans dans les dans les dans les
dans les toits c'est
magnifique c'est très serré dans les
toits tu ça
après
des dans les Noirs ça
tropop à partir de là c'est
bon
av un tout petit peu plus haut peut-être
pour voir un peu plus
de relief du village un peu trop
[Musique]
peêre fa vraiment un ple plein cadre de
vageintériur à gauche du C il y a la
maison pourrie je crois j'ai
l'impression maison pour très loin ah
oui d'accord très large ou ok on a
encore des problèmes
dans on a le fa contact qui revient là
ouais là c'est pas bon ou
j'ai pas l'impression que ça vibre
là c'est pas bon hein c'est pas
bon c'est quoi quoi alors on je le vois
l'ocyo monte un petit peu monte un tout
petit peu alle on proche du village et
là tu même en plan fixe montre encore un
tout petit peu Fran voilà rentre dans
rentre dans le village s'il te plaît en
placardre ça va là ça va avance un petit
peu Fran c'est dans cet AX là voilà tu
VO voilàas le paysage derrière tuas tout
le village devant tuas les rochers tuas
le un peu plus sur ta gauche tuuras plus
de matière du village surout surtout lui
sur tu
vas la matière est absolument sublime
làdedans tuas un mec qui te regardeas
des trucs faut taper dedans les enfants
là détails
voilà ton point euh oui
d'accord mon un tout petit peu plus haut
peut-être
elle était belle la gazelle qui est
sortie de ta chambre
Stéphane c'est bon là comme ça c'est
super beau ça doucement doucement comme
ça Fran c'est
bon d'abord ce plan
là coup tuas dit couper
ou moi j'ai vas-y
je un peu plus voilà voilà voilà voilà
un peu làdedans voilà détail des gens
qui nous regardent c'est vachement beau
ça
voilà et
coupe un peu plus V voilà tu
me
voir
super beau ça doucement
doucement comme c'est beau doucement
doucement doucement doucement doucement
c'est à mon
avis le temps de voir le temps de
regarder un peu làdedans tu
vois incroyable ce village pas de soleil
dessus par contre mais
bon tu vois ça c'est beau
là bouge un peu dedans un peu de
mouvement peut-être
les ball point comment ils sont bien
rangés sur les toits et
ouis pas un petit coup de soleil là
ouais c'est
[Musique]
dommage
c'est bon c'est magnifique ça c'est
magnifique ça c'est très très beau
ça plan
ça un peu de
lumière
on va on va à la pointe pas c'est
pe-être non pour voir de la
[Musique]
pointe
c'est bon
to ce plan qu'on pas fait tout à l'heure
qui do pas mal voilà
voilà c'est plus beau d'ailleurs ça
comme
ça bien vers la droite c'est beau
çaas
les arrête-toi quand même un moment
parce que c'est
parti coup toi euh essaye un truc s'il
te plaît pour moi un petit mouvement
s'il te plaît do tourner autour
quoier plus vers la gauche vers ta
gauche en te rapprochant un petit peu si
tu peux pu pe en grimpant après je sais
pas
il peux tenir le point quand on
monte C toit
c'est Ji à gauche doucement doucement
doucement doucement
doucement
des mecs en bas qui travaillent c'est
génial trop
ser on peut monter ou pas ça t'embête ou
pas vasy doucement douement tu vas
dessus sur le village
monant ple mati
dedans ça Stéphan ouais voilà ça j'adore
c'est ça que j'aime ça j'adore j'adore
j'adore ce plan j'adore
ça masqu au milieu
voil masqu à gauche c'est
bon un peu de vie on voit des gens
bouger tu vois ça bouge les gens
regardent pas c'est
top
de masqué on efface tout
droit attendsends tu vas t'arrêter
là-dessus vas-y vas-y vas-y vas-y
vas-y avance
avancecou tu m'a dit arrêtez oui c'est
moi qui dit une connerie dis-moi diso
voilà regarde tu vois tuas les gens tous
les gens en train de
joli ball vachement bien rangé V ha
c'est
magnifique que
je arrête
de juste que j'que contre jour je vois
rien personne ren mais si il y a des
écrans tu vois parfaitement
mon un petit mouvement maintenant je l'
en vertical c'est génial petit carré de
famille où les gens viventis tu sens
vachement bien
le
mer
en vertical c'est top ça bon on fait les
bonnes femes avec les oignons un petit
[Musique]
plan
un pe
ser allez coupe on est bon pour le
village
là
Mo destro en
face
coupe regarde à droite
droite allez
[Musique]
Vy
chercher quel pour mon
truc
[Musique]
c'est pas monter des le village
après
[Musique]
ok sont les oignons c'est joli c'est la
c'est la matière de c'est